I almost got married once.
Wentworth held my heart.
But he was a sailor
without rank or fortune.
And I was persuaded
to give him up.
Now I'm single and thriving.
I spend my time
drinking fine wines,
enjoying warm baths…
and lying face down
on my bed.
Like I said, thriving.
Who needs romance
when one has…
family?
My father.
He's never met a reflective
surface he didn't like.
Vanity is the beginning
and end of his character.
Also the middle.
"Sir Walter Elliot,
born March 1st, 1760."
"Man of consequence,
known for his
exquisite jawline."
He is the sole object
of his own warmest respect
and devotion.
One's family is only
escapable by two things:
marriage and death.
Both seem unlikely
in the immediate future.
"Married July 15th, 1784,
to Jane."
My mother.
-I miss her.
-"Jane died in 1801."
"By her, Sir Walter issued
three children."
My sisters.
"Elizabeth,
celebrated beauty
and Somerset's most
fashion-forward luminary."
Elizabeth, the eldest.
"Mary, married
to Charles Musgrove,
heir to the superior
Uppercross estate."
Mary, the youngest.
"And Anne,
born August 9th, 1787."
And me, middle child,
the crack
in his looking glass.
Shame there wasn't
anything nice
we could think to add
about you, Anne.
Thanks for trying.
You're quite welcome.
I wanted to leave
you out entirely,
but Daddy thought people
might think you had died.
-Debt collectors.
-Daddy.
Daddy!
The one thing my father
loves more than himself
is spending money.
It was always going
to run out one day.
-Daddy…
-Daddy's broke, princess.
Playtime's over.
There, there.